when we are reaching the end of a long
bargaining process and usually as you're
approaching the end the noise to signal
ratio peaks and so how much more time do
we have now well objectively speaking we
have until the 30th of june because this
is when the extension of our loan
agreement with our creditors expires
okay but the subjective but
pragmatically a lot of people have been
saying it's hours away from smile on
said it was hours away just yesterday do
you do you agree with that I have no
doubt that we could have a comprehensive
deal one that these therapeutic for
Greece and good for Europe overnight
Europe usually does this overnight in
the early hours of the morning and I
have no reason to doubt that such an a
long night could produce a very good
agreement okay did in terms of long
night tomorrow there is a payment jus to
the eye on a three hundred million euros
is that a meager teammate well let me
say that for the last four months we've
been making every single payment even
though no disbursements have been
forthcoming from the creditors we will
continue and continue to attempt to
extract from as I say the fiber of this
state the last ounce of liquidity to
meet those payments but at some point
and I'm not going to speculate as to
what that point is there will be super
seniority afforded to wages and pensions
so what does that mean that means the
loans don't get repaid to the IMF the
ECB super senior living it's a question
of ranking special ranking so you pay
double pay what we can and you think at
some points what does that mean at some
point well this is your interpretation
you said at some point that there is a
point where that kicks in yes I did do
you know what that point is maybe I do
but it was being pertinent for you to
ask me to share this information with
you well
when it is well it will be important for
you to ask me ok so the imap loan is
tomorrow the repayments there it takes a
while to go through has that process
begun to start paying it off a lots of
processes are in progress what's the
process it to you do you feel that at
the moment you know there's this
liquidity crisis the country is
essentially running out of money at the
moment we see it you know we see
projects that have been halted at the
moment what does that make you know as
the finance minister you're seeing that
happening is that of course that causes
you quite a lot of pain it does indeed
but this is a price we have to pay for
the right to negotiate because this
liquidity crisis is politically
engineered by our creditors to try to
squeeze us into effectively perpetuating
these dead deflationary crisis think
about what has been happening over the
last five years we have been this this
nation this country different
governments of course they have been
adding bad debt on existing but at debt
on conditions of austerity that it uses
the income's from which those but that
will have to be repaid this is not
sensible and what we decided to do
before we were elected and then we
implemented it is to say no to this to
say we're going to take time out we're
going to negotiate with our credit
there's a sensible solution but puts an
end to this vicious cycle the price we
have to pay was that we were being
squeezed intentionally bar creditors
they respond spirit lies on the other
side what we want is a situation where
we managed to reach an agreement that is
mutually beneficial the agreement that
has been proposed last the agreement
that was imposed upon previous
governments was not beneficial either to
Greece or to Europe it's about time that
we find common ground and ways of
serving our common interests it's one
thing that being seeing the irving
fisher debt deflation
that are happening now and it's another
thing being in government and actually
being able to to do something about it
does that process being tougher than you
thought it would be no I always thought
it was going to be tough the whole point
of our election was to end this Irving
Fisher like that deflationary cycle and
we're not going simply to sign off on an
agreement that doesn't do it alternator
the one they all you have for you at the
moment not really it's not an ultimatum
it was a series of proposals on the
other side we take their own proposals
this is what the negotiation is all
about that is all about I don't think
that civilized the nations and
institutions issue ultimate anymore and
I have every confidence that Europe in
the last moment after it it has tried
all other alternatives will do the right
thing we don't we're not there yes no
end of this month it must be so okay all
right so there's still some time left
but top negotiation with Texas what were
you not in Brussels were you here
because I have a finance minister
ministry to run and finance ministers to
not talk to them this is that the
protocol is the finance ministers doctor
finance ministers so if dr. Schreiber
was there i would be there is my final
question is we a lot of people say not
not much has actually happens in terms
of domestic policy in the last six
months and that's a frustration you know
the country civil service is almost
ground to a halt well these negotiations
happen and it's very difficult for the
economy for people living their lives
well two quick points firstly we have
introduced legislation which was
considered by our creditors to have been
unilateral actions that they didn't like
so this negotiation has been for stating
because we have not been able to carry
out the reforms that we wanted to carry
out but we still managed to carry out
several reforms that have been important
we're looking very much forward to the
conclusion of the Connecticut
negotiation so that this backlog of
reform bills can be rushed through
Parliament